hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel if you are here to learn
the data science algorithms then you are
at the right place this data science
algorithms video will cover the most
important algorithms that would help you
in real life scenarios also if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel
we have daily updates on multiple
technologies and don't forget to hit
that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from us
so without further ado let's dive into
the agenda for today's discussion so we
will be learning the data science
algorithms today by going through the
following docket at first we will learn
the logistic regression in r then we
will move ahead and know what is a
decision tree followed by that we will
understand what is clustering next we
will learn divisive clustering later the
support vector machine advancing ahead
we will have the k-means clustering and
lastly we will wind up the session by
learning time series analysis i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
escalating over to our training experts
hello and welcome to logistic regression
in r my name is pete ferrari and i am
with the simply learn team and today
we're going to cover logistic regression
in the r programming language logistic
regression is kind of a misnomer in that
when most people think of regression
they think of linear regression which is
a machine learning algorithm for
continuous variables however logistic
regression is a classification algorithm
not a continuous variable prediction
algorithm logistic regression is also
sometimes called logit regression in
this video we are going to learn why we
would use regression as a predictive
algorithm
what is regression the different types
of regression as i've already mentioned
some regression algorithms are
classification algorithms and some are
continuous variable algorithms why use
logistic regression what is logistic
regression and then we'll look at a use
case a college admission uh using
logistic regression so why would we use
regression well let's say we had a
website and our revenue was based on the
traffic that we could drive to that
website whether through r d or marketing
and we wanted to predict the revenue
based on site traffic and the website
traffic would be related to the revenue
we could generate the more traffic
driven to our website then the higher
our revenue or at least that's what we
would intuitively assume and so we need
to predict the revenue based on our
website traffic here we have the plot of
revenue versus website traffic traffic
would be considered the independent
variable and revenue would be the
dependent variable often the independent
variable or variables if we had more
than one could be called the explanatory
variables and the dependent variable
would be called the response variable
however we typically refer to them as
independent and dependent variables so
our intuition tells us that the
independent variable drives the
dependent variable and if there is some
relationship between the two variables
then we would say that there is a
correlation between the two variables
and then we may be able to use the
independent variable to make predictions
about the dependent variable if you look
at the chart on the right you'll see
there is a clear trend between website
traffic and revenue as website traffic
increases the revenue increases and we
could draw a line to show that
relationship and then we could use that
line as a predictor line so for example
what will revenue be if our traffic is
4.5 k and we see that when the traffic
is around 4 500 the revenue is around 13
000 and if we could draw a perpendicular
line from 4.5 k on the axis on the
x-axis the traffic axis up to the orange
regression line sometimes called the
line of best fit then we could draw
another line over to the y axis the
revenue axis and we could see where it
lands and that would be the prediction
so in this example when the traffic is
around 45
000 hits the predicted revenue is around
13 000. normally we wouldn't actually
draw those lines we would generate an
equation and we would call that equation
a model and we could plug the
independent variable into the equation
to generate the dependent variable
output which we would call our
prediction so what is regression
regression is a statistical relationship
between two or more variables where a
change in the independent variable is
associated with a change in the
dependent variable it's important to
note that all variables are related to
each other for example a person's
favorite color may not be related to
revenue from a website here the change
in one variable height is closely
associated with the change in the other
variable age this makes intuitive sense
as you get older from when you're born
you get taller and it seems to make
sense if we plot that data we would see
those green points on the graph up to
some certain age where growth would
taper off in the plot in the middle of
the screen we see the clear linear
relationship between age and height
which is indicated by the solid red line
we sometimes call that line a trend line
or a regression line or the line of best
fit and we see that the height is the
dependent variable and age is the
independent variable of course you might
ask doesn't height depend on other
factors of course it does but here we're
looking at the relationship between two
variables one independent and one
dependent age and height there are
various types of regression linear
regression logistic regression multiple
linear regression polynomial regression
and there are others decision tree
regression random forest regression but
linear regression is probably the most
well known by definition when there is a
linear relationship between a dependent
variable which is continuous in an
independent variable which is continuous
or discrete we would use linear
regression when the y value in the graph
is categorical such as yes or no two or
false they voted they did not vote they
purchased something they did not
purchase something it depends on the x
variable logistic regression is when the
y value in the graph is categorical in
nature for example yes no purchased
don't purchase voted did not vote and it
depends on the x variable notice the
trend line for linear regression and the
line for logistic regression they're
different more on that later and there's
polynomial regression as well when the
relation between the dependent variable
y and the independent variable x is in
the nth degree of x sometimes we say an
nth degree polynomial of x in this
picture you can see that the
relationship is not linear there's a
curve to that best fit trendline so why
would we use logistic regression and we
need to understand why we would use
logistic regression and that linear
regression picking the machine learning
algorithm for your problem is no small
task and it really behooves us to
understand the difference between these
machine learning algorithms linear
regression answers the question how much
so in our earlier example if website
traffic grows then how much would
revenue grow whereas logistic regression
would answer what will happen or not
happen linear regression in general is
used to predict a continuous variable
like height and weight logistic
regression is used when a response
variable only has two outcomes yes or no
two or faults often we refer to logistic
regression as a binary classifier since
there are only two outcomes so let's try
to understand this with an example let's
say we have a startup company and we are
trying to figure out whether the startup
will be profitable or not that's binary
with two possible outcomes profitable or
not profitable and let's use initial
funding to be the independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear once
again our intuition tells us that the
more funding a startup has the more
profitable it will be but of course data
science doesn't depend on intuition it
depends on data but this graph does not
tell whether the startup will be
profitable yes or no it only states that
with an increase in funding the profit
also increases that's not binary if we
wanted to predict how much profit then
linear regression would be useful but
that's not what we are being asked hence
we need to make use of logistic
regression which has two outcomes in our
case profitable and not profitable so
let's draw a graph again the x-axis will
be our independent variable funding and
the y-axis will no longer be the
dependent variable profit but it will be
the probability of profit for example if
you look at a company with a funding of
say 40 then the probability that that
company will be profitable is around
point eight or eighty percent based on
the best fit line called a sigmoid curve
in the example we plotted several
companies some with 10 15 20 some with
50 60 or 70 or 65 and we indicated
whether they were zero not profitable or
a one profitable on the graph and this
is how we should think of logistic
regression in this example given the
amount of funding we calculate the
probability that a company will be
profitable or not profitable and if we
use the threshold line of 50 then we
have our classifier if the probability
is 50 or higher the company is
profitable if the probability is lower
than 50 it's not profitable so what is
logistic regression this is a linear
regression graph so let's compare linear
regression to logistic regression and
take a look at the trend line that
describes the model it's a straight line
which is why we call it linear
regression but using linear regression
we can't really divide the output into
two distinct categories yes or no to
divide our results into two categories
we would have to clip the line between
zero and one if you recall probabilities
can only be between zero and one and if
we're going to use probability on the y
axis then we can't have anything that is
below zero or above one thus we would
have to clip the line and once we clip
the line we see that the resulting curve
cannot be represented in a linear
equation so for logistic regression we
will make use of a sigmoid function and
the sigmoid curve is the line of best
fit notice that it's not linear but it
does satisfy our requirement of using a
single line that does not need to be
clipped for linear regression we would
use an equation of a straight line y
equals b sub 0 plus b sub 1 times x x
being the independent variable y being
the dependent variable but as we've said
we cannot use a linear equation for
binary predictions so we need to use the
sigmoid function which is represented by
the equation p equals 1 divided by the
quantity 1 plus e to the minus y e being
the base of the natural logs then taking
the log of both sides and solving we get
our sigmoid function and graphing it we
get our logistic regression line of best
fit the applications for logistic
regression are endless here we might
have a couple of gardeners or farmers
and one farmer says i am planning to
grow plants in my backyard and i want to
know whether my trees will get infested
with bugs which i'm sure is a huge
problem and these days the fewer
pesticides we use the better off we are
for health reasons the young lady says i
can use logistic regression in a model
to predict it for you and the other
farmer says well how is logistic
regression going to help but we know
that healthy versus not healthy is a
binary classification and we can use a
binary classifier like logistic
regression to solve this problem which
is what the young lady has in mind if we
have the data we can model the data and
generate a sigmoid function that best
fits our data and then use the
probability of a healthy tree versus a
not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again we see our sigmoid line of
best fit and some points that represent
healthy trees and not healthy trees once
again we plot our sigmoid curve scratch
that and once again once our sigmoid
curve is plotted and our threshold is
set almost always at 50 percent we can
use the sigmoid curve and calculate the
probabilities and hear the independent
variable of width which i assume is an
application of pesticides or no
pesticides to determine whether or not
the probability of healthy is greater
than 50 percent the threshold or less
than 50 percent the threshold and now
let's take a use case of a college
admission problem of course we can't
solve anything using data science if we
don't know what the problem is so we
need a problem statement and here the
problem statement is simple we are given
a data set and we need to predict
whether a candidate will get admission
in a desired college or not based on
their gpa and college rank so the very
first thing we need to do is import the
data set and if it's a small enough data
set and it can fit into our computer
memory then we are golden otherwise we
have some work to do the data set that
we were given is in csv format comma
separated values csv files are easily
imported into our environment once we
import the data we next need to select
and import the libraries that we will
need although r is a great programming
language with a lot of built-in
functions it is easily and powerfully
extended by the use of libraries and
packages then we need to split the data
set into a training set and a test set
it's important to note that the data set
that we've imported that we were given
has the gpas and college ranks for
several students but it also has a
column that indicates whether those
students were admitted or not so what
we're saying is that the data set has
the answers and if you think about it it
must how could we possibly train a model
have a model learn if we didn't know the
answers already that's why it's called
machine learning so we train the model
and then we test the model once we split
the data into training and test sets we
will apply our regression on the two
independent variables gpa and rank
generate the model and then run the test
set through the model once that is
complete we will validate the model to
see how well it performed so now it's
demo time so here we have our studio my
favorite ide or integrated development
environment and i have a script already
composed to run our logistic regression
on the problem at hand which is our
college admissions problem so let's just
walk down the script before i run it and
talk about the various points in the
script so first define the problem well
the problem was defined and you really
can't do anything in data science
without a clear problem definition once
the problems defined you can load your
libraries acquire your data set the
working directory in my case i'm on
windows explore the data mung the data
if necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets then
train the model using the training data
and run the test data through the model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision etc so here we are going
to load our libraries i'm going to use a
package called ca tools and now that the
library is loaded i'm going to set my
working directory and if i come over
here to the files tab you'll see that
there is my working directory in that
working directory there's a file called
binary.csv
and that's the csv the comma separated
value file that the college gave me i'm
going to ingest and then look at that
data and as you can see it has four
columns gre gpa rank and then the answer
column admit whether or not someone was
admitted which would be a one or not
admitted which would be a zero and if we
come over to the right and we can look
and see some of the first few values of
each of those four columns now let's
split the data we're going to take this
my data frame and split it into two a
training set and a test set and the
ratio we're going to use is 80 20. so 80
of the data will go into the training
set and 20 will go into the test set now
that ratio could be 60 40 it could be 70
30. typically it really depends on the
size of your data how much data you have
but this is for our example and for our
purposes 80 20 is perfect next we'll do
a little data munching in general you
munge the data early on after ingestion
and you really have to be careful in
this case we don't have any missing
values we don't have any real outliers
our data was pretty clean when we got it
and ingested it but in general that's
not the case and a lot of work and a lot
of attention needs to be paid to the
munging process here we're just going to
take our data the admission column and
the rank column and convert them to
categorical variables right now they're
integers as you can see on the right
hand side and once i run these two lines
they will be converted to factors and
all the fun stuff we're going to use the
glm function the general linear model
function to train our logistic
regression model and the dependent
variable is admit and the independent
variables are gpa and rank and the
little tilde sign here says the
dependent variable will be a function of
gpa and rank the two independent
variables the data will be the training
set and the family will be binomial and
binomial indicates that it's a binary
classifier it's a logistic regression
problem there it is we ran our model and
there's a summary of our model you can
see that there is some statistical
significance in gpa and in rank by the
coefficients and output of the model so
next let's run the test data through the
model
and once we have done all that we can
now set up a confusion matrix and look
at our predictions versus the actual
values again this is important we had
the answers and now we took and we
predicted some answers so hopefully our
predicted answers match up with the
actual answers we'll run a confusion
matrix as you can see the predicted
values versus the actual values and it's
important here to note that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27 we did well on those but
there are a few that were predicted
incorrectly some were predicted true but
were actually false some were predicted
false that were actually true and now
we'll confirm what our percentage
accuracy is 72 not bad but we could
probably do better how we'll leave that
to another video what is a decision tree
and here we have kind of a new looking
front panel of a car driving down the
street and we have uh left or right so
you're coming to an intersection you
gotta decide which way to go are you
gonna go left or you're gonna go right
wait or go so do you go right away we
have a green light so probably want to
go right away after you check for cross
traffic make sure no one is asleep at
the wheel or talking on their cell phone
decision tree is a tree shaped algorithm
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
so another example is we have a
shopkeeper very non-descript shopkeeper
kind of a little spooky without the eyes
so we have a shopkeeper and he wants to
organize his stall so i must organize my
stall and just looking around trying to
figure out what the best way to stack
all his goods are and he has some
broccoli some oranges and some carrots
this is kind of a nice example because
we can see where some of the colors and
shapes overlap where others don't and so
you can create a tree out of this very
easily and say is it colored orange if
it's not well it goes into one stack
well that happens to be all their
broccoli and if it is colored orange
then it goes into another stack and
you're like well that's still kind of
chaotic you know people are looking at
carrots and oranges a very strange
combination to put in a box so the next
question might be is it round and if it
is then yes you put the oranges into one
box and no that means it's carrots we
put in the other box and you can see
that a lot of stuff we do
in life easily can fall into like a
decision tree how do you decide
something you know does it go left does
it go right yes or no and even with this
we even have a number of different end
choices broccoli carrots and oranges so
what kind of problems does this solve
what problems can be solved by using a
decision tree classification we're
dealing with a classification
identifying to which set an object
belongs and from our example we just
looked at a is orange while broccoli is
green i guess it's non-descript day
without the faces i love it because a
lot of times you're looking at data you
really don't want to know what exactly
the data is but you're sorting it so you
know like this kind of represents data
that you really don't know exactly where
it's coming from just kind of a fun
thing regression regression is another
problem the biggest can be solved
regression problems have continuous or
numerical valued output variables
example predicting the profits of a
company so we have two different primary
problems we solve for we solve for
classification is it green or is it
orange and we solve for regression which
is a continual number so you know if
you're doing stocks this would be a
dollar value that ranges anywhere from
zero to thousands of dollars
how does a decision tree work terms you
must know first so before we dive into
the decision tree let's look at some of
the terminology for the decision tree we
have notes each internal node in a
decision tree is a test which splits the
objects into different categories and
continuing with our vegetable stand
example we have broccoli no it's not
orange and
oranges and carrots are and so on so you
can see right there where it splits
that's a note where the orange is split
in the carrot split into each of their
own groups and each one of the splits is
a node the very top note of the decision
tree is called the root node so the very
first one we started off where we split
it is a colored orange
and you can see that pointed out nice
and neatly there this is a root note at
the top each external node in a decision
tree is called the leaf node the leaf
node is the output and you can see down
here we have our broccoli and we have
our carrots and our oranges each one of
those is a leaf node so to quickly
rehash our terms we have anywhere there
is a split that's a node and if it's at
the very top of the tree that's the root
node and if you're at the very bottom of
the tree where you have a final answer
that is the leaf node so you have a root
node a leaf node and then everything
else is just a generic node so one of
the most important terms or concepts
that powers a decision tree is entropy
entropy is a measure of the messiness of
your data collection the messier or more
random your data higher will be the
entropy so we can see here we have
broccoli oranges and carrots are all
mixed together and it's very chaotic
and you could say this collection has
high entropy
and if we sort out the carrots out of
here within i guess just one of the
broccoli i don't know where the other
broccoli went you could say if you have
just the oranges and the broccoli this
is a lower entropy they say this
collection has low entropy but really
it's higher and lower one is higher or
lower than the other one and from
entropy we get information gain
information is the decrease obtained in
entropy by splitting the data set u
based on some conditioning so we have
our information one which we can
actually there's actual computations and
so we have our e1 which is put in there
for our entropy value at the base node
or root node and we have two a2 which is
a leaf node and so we can actually
calculate just calculations for entropy
and we actually look at those two values
the entropy and we take that we have e1
is greater than e2 therefore the
information gain equals e1 minus e2 so
here we have another example and we're
actually going to attach some values to
this one in just a moment so we're going
to move away from the fruit and we're
going to go to everybody's favorite
thing organizing a child's closet and
here we have a young lady waving at us
hi my cupboard is a mess i must organize
my stuff and we're going to classify the
objects based on their attribute set
using a decision tree we can look at it
we have a shape a size and a label and a
number and i'm going to go ahead and
look at the labels because that's really
what's key on this one is we have a
couple of balls in here some books cards
and blocks and if you look at that when
you have something that's a ball it's
round so it's a very different shape the
book card and blocks are all rectangular
but the books are a different size so
the books have like a size six i guess
they think of them as very large cards a
size four so they're not quite as big
and the blocks are little lego blocks it
looks like kind of fun to stack on there
and then we can actually quantify this
and we can actually say hey we got we
have different numbers we have two balls
two books one card four blocks and we
split at each level based on certain
conditions on the attributes so
splitting aims at reducing the entropy
and we have a formula our first actual
formula you'll see it happens in the
background when we're running these
different modules in r it looks a little
complicated but we can break that up and
simplify that for you so we see this
formula the negative sum of i of x
equals the probability of 1
value of x times the log of 2
probability value of x the term
probability value of x it's probably
easiest to understand if we go ahead and
put the numbers in there so you can
actually see what we're looking at and
so we plug the numbers in there we look
at the probability of the value of x
well if we do the number of balls
there's two balls and the total number
of items is nine so we have a
probability of any one object being two
out of nine so that's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can calculate our
entropy of two over nine times the
squared log of two over nine plus one
ninth the log squared of one over nine
plus four over nine times the log
squared of four over nine so our whole
group is the sum of all the entropies
and so when we look at that we have the
entropy of the balls which is the two
over nine rectangles two over nine i
mean books two over nine cards one over
nine and the blocks four over nine and
we just plug those numbers in there and
we get an actual value of
1.8282 so what the heck does a module do
with that number well now we must find
the conditions for our split every split
must give us the maximum achievable
information gain and so we have our
first entropy value 1.8282
and it turns out when you compare all
the different individual entropy values
for the balls for the books for the
cards for the blocks rectangles
you find out that the biggest split is
going to be in the shape and it's going
to be our first split will be on the
shape that will directly segregate the
balls out so they'll split up a huge
group from one from the other and so we
compute that we end up with e2 which is
all of our rectangles and then we have a
leaf node which is the balls and so with
our e2 we see that 1.3784 is much less
than the 1.8282
and so our second split will be on the
size as that will directly segregate the
books and so we do that we can see that
if the size is greater than five all the
books go to one side while the cards and
the blocks go to the other and again we
have our e3 which equals 0.716 which is
considerably less than 1.3784 so our
entropy is dropping each time we do a
split and of course our third split we
look at and we'll see that we're left
with size again and we'd split it with
four and two in this case if it's
greater than three it's going to be a
block if it's less than three it's going
to be a card and at this point each of
our objects is looped into similarities
so they all look the same and we end up
with an entropy of zero and so you can
see as we go down the entropy continues
to get less and because it hits zero we
can say all our objects are now
classified with a hundred percent
accuracy if it was only that easy to
clean the kids closets and you can see
we have a nice drawing that shows you
where all the leaf nodes are on this in
which case we have the balls the books
the blocks and the cards are part of the
leaf note and the root node is our first
split we have all the object and we're
splitting them by rectangle by shape so
we're going to dive into the use case
and in this case we're going to get a
little morbid there i am behind my desk
that's definitely not me i don't have
that big of a chin but
i do usually have a cup of coffee and it
looks kind of like that it's sitting
next to me on my desk so the use case is
going to be survival prediction in r and
let's implement a classification of data
set based on information
gain
this is going to use the id3 algorithm
don't let that scare you that's the most
common algorithm they use to calculate
the decision tree there's a couple
different ways they can calculate the
entropy but the formula is all the same
behind it so id3 is most common in r and
then we'll be using the rstudio for our
interface for our ide so rstudio is free
to download there's the free version of
course there's an enterprise version and
there's all kinds of different choices
in there but one of the wonderful things
about r is that it's been an open source
for a very long time and is very well
developed it's also very quick and easy
to use on a lot of things so this is
going to be in the r studio
there's some other interfaces but this
is i would suggest using the r studio
it's the most common one and if you
remember i said this is going to be a
little morbid because we're talking
about how many people survived and died
on these ships so in this case we have a
nice vacation cruise ship going on there
or i'm not sure what that is with the
tugboat so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers we will develop a model that
recognizes the relationship between
these factors and predicts the survival
of a passenger accordingly so we want to
predict whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not so we're going to look at this
data and if you open it up into a
spreadsheet and don't forget you can
always put a note on the youtube video
down below and we will be monitoring
that you can request the data set sent
to you or more correspondence you can
also go to
www.simplylearn.com and request this
data set too it's just a simple csv file
we'll send out and you can see right
here we have survived so one indicates a
person survived the wreck
zero they didn't make it they were under
the water and the luxury class of the
cabin so if they were in you know what
what values like one two three depending
on what luxury class they were and then
we have this is kind of interesting how
many siblings they had so it's kind of
an interesting added statistic in there
number of parents on board and disembark
location so where the destination is
so here we've opened up rstudio and if
this is your first time in our studio
you'll notice that it opens up
standardly in three panes
the upper left is for text documents
you're bringing in and then the bottom
left is the actual commands as they're
processed and then on the right hand
side you have your environment set up on
there now i've zoomed in with my font a
little oversized in fact we can even
take that up one more size and see if we
can get a larger setup view here we go
so i've set the font for 18 probably a
lot larger than you need to work on a
project and the first thing i'm going to
do is on the right hand panel we're
going to be working with plots so i'm
going to click on the little plot tab up
there and i'm just going to collapse
that over to the side for right now and
then i'm going to open up the bottom one
and you'll see on the top i actually
have two different tabs team in the back
was really nice to set up the whole
package for what we're working on here
and we'll go through this line by line
and then you'll see as we execute the
different lines they're going to appear
down below so i'll be flipping between
these two left panels and let me go
backwards just for a second here we're
going to do
this part
so let's take a look at the installs
and if you look at the installs and when
i'm not going to actually run the
installs because i've already run them
on my computer so these are already
installed in my r packages and i don't
have to re-run them
we have a number of packages we're
bringing into our because that's how r
functions and the first number of
packages are all part of our decision
tree so our f selector our r part our
carrot with the dependencies equal true
and our dp lyr and our r part plot oh
that's a mouthful you'll need to import
all of these in your setup
and the first one which is your f
selector compute your chi squared your
information gain your entropy all of
those formulas are a part of the f
selectors when you bring it in that's
what that package is the r part is your
partitioning of your decision tree so
these are your primary two decision tree
modules that we're bringing in
the carrot is a part for actually
splitting apart the data because we
always want to do a test set a train set
so they built a package carrot to kind
of handle all those you'll see carrot
used a lot of other machine learning
packages when you're doing the r the
dplyr
is for mutating your data so you can sum
it you can classify it you can filter it
that's all part of the
dplyr and then our part has another
piece called plot and that's for helping
us plot the data as we sort out the tree
because the art part creates a tree but
you still want to be able to plot it and
then we come down here and we have some
additional tools we're going to work
with a spreadsheet this is a microsoft
access spreadsheet so we're going to use
the xlsx package to import it and you
might think that's a little outdated
because i know when i'm doing any new
projects i try to save my data into a
comma separated variable file or
something more standardized
a lot of times you'll end up with these
old databases where they're exporting
data and their export comes in an excel
spreadsheet and guess what this is a
time saver instead of opening up the
spreadsheet resaving it as a comma
separated variable file you can just
open it right up in r which is really
nice and then we have our data tree
which goes right along with displaying
the data so we have our rpart.plot and
we're going to put that into the data
trees have a nice visual and finally you
need to install the package ca tools
and ca tools is another package used for
general manipulation of your data and
your vectors so it also has a split
function for training data i know we
have another package for that but both
those packages fit in there as far as
the working with the data so a lot of
times you'll see these loaded in there
together and you'll see in a moment
we'll import the elementary stat learn
package also which is very generic
working with data setup as far as
statistics and data processing now
because
my java setup is a little different
because i use the developer package well
the latest update of the developer
package and the r are struggling to see
each other so i need to go ahead and add
this in chances are you don't need to
worry about this but if you do get an r
java error you'll need to go ahead and
add an align to set your environment and
i'm just going to set the java home i
went ahead and looked up the last solid
jre folder you'll see under program
files java you can look them all up to
make sure it's the jre and not the jdk
the difference between those is one is a
standard executable that's a jre folder
it is a folder not an actual file and
the jdk deals more with developer side
on things and i'm going to go ahead and
run this and if you're in r you can run
these lines individually by holding your
control key down and hitting the enter
button so i've now loaded my workspace
and set my environment here and we can
actually look and just make sure a
system dot
get environment is the opposite one and
i can just look real quick and say hey
what's my java
home set to
and if i run that
oops i forgot to put brackets around it
there we go
and if i do that you'll see that it's
set to the jdk18025
and again we're looking at the split
screen and let me just move this up here
a little bit and let me hit the enter
key a bunch of times it comes up on the
screen
when i run it and i'm running it line by
line the run text then appears down here
and this is what's actually being
executed so i could just as easily type
it in down here
as putting it up here on the top part
that's just a little bit of r studio and
working with rstudio
so i've shown you the installs and again
i've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it
we need to go ahead and then bring those
libraries in to work with
so
basically we're going through all the
different libraries we're using
elements.learn is a standard r library
so it should already be installed you
don't have to install that one and i can
just go right down them and you'll see
as i install them that they show up on
the bottom
and every time you go to run a new setup
you need to go ahead and install these
pull the libraries in you got to tell
your r studio these are the libraries
you're using
and you can see right down here that
as it executes them
it has all the different things one of
them had like a couple different parts
to it so loaded the lattice and the gg
plot to
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here so if you start
getting error codes
then you might have to go troubleshoot
and find out why it's not installing
correctly or did it install correctly
but it's pretty straightforward we've
covered all the libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply let a comment down below on
the youtube video or visit
www.simplylearn.com and they'll be happy
to send you a copy of the base code
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the excel file
after setting the working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory scwd is a command for that in
r
and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to in your files
too a lot of times if you get the zipped
framework sent to you it will unzip all
into one location
and then you can look that location up
and put that in here a lot of times it
automatically sets that for you if you
if you're working the same directory
in this case you can see i've pasted in
a very lengthy
path because i have this as part of my
documents my business docs and simply
learn and marketing videos and so on
i'll go ahead and do the control enter
and run that so now my working directory
is set and you can see down below it's
executed this on the
console down here
and if i open up that working directory
you can see i have a ship xls file
that's the data we're going to look at
and we looked at that on the slide
you could also open this up and i want
to go ahead and open it up with a
notepad
by default it will open up as a
spreadsheet
oh it is an excel file so i'd have to
open it up as an actual spreadsheet
wasn't thinking that one through this is
one of the problems with saving stuff as
a proprietary ship soft file even
something as widely used as microsoft
excel spreadsheet
but when we open up the spreadsheet you
can see here the same data we looked at
before
that's what's coming up in this file
and so i take this file we can go ahead
and let's um
create a variable we'll call it add
and we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser than dash means
if you've never used r before and we're
just going to assign it a ship xlsx
and then i'll do my control enter and
you'll see it run down here ship
add is assign shipped.xls
our excel spreadsheet on there
and then let's have another variable
we'll call it df for data frame and
we're going to assign this read
x l s x and that's from the library sl x
x that we just imported
and we want to read the file add
because we just created that variable
with the ship.xls
and i didn't catch this right away but
you'll see when we open it up in a
spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has a the first sheet is
called ship one so this data is on the
page ship one in the excel spreadsheet
and we got to make sure that we tell the
reader to look for that
and so we can simply do that in our
command line
sheet name equals
and it was ship one on there
so we go ahead and hit the control enter
and run this line and it brings it down
below and executes it
it's now reading in that data from that
spreadsheet that's what's going on and
it takes just a moment to go ahead and
read it in
and then with any
data processing we need to select the
meaningful columns for the prediction so
this is important that we sort through
our data and set it correctly so that
whatever we're feeding it into can read
it correctly
we can do this with
df
we're going to reassign it and we're
going to select
and from there we're going to select df
as our our main data frame going in
and then list the columns that we want
and if we look at the
data we have survived we have a class we
have a name sex and age
and then there's siblings and parents
we really don't want to know the name
because we don't need the name to run
this on here and then we gotta decide
which one of these we want to work with
and the guys in the back played with the
data a little bit and they came up with
the following columns
survived which we need definitely
because that's what we're actually
trying to figure out is whether we're
going to survive or not
what class they're which which class of
the boat they're writing in their first
class second class
sex and age we went ahead and dropped
the rest of them at least for this
example
and so i can go ahead and do my control
enter and you'll see it execute down
below
and now df
equals these three columns or
four columns
plus our answer is one of those so i
always think of it as three columns plus
one
but it is four columns
and then for the next step we want to
make sure the data is in the right
format so again i'm going to resign the
df
and we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're going to
let it know what kind of data that is
so our first one is let me put the
database in or the data frame in there
df
and then we want to go ahead and do
survived equals a factor of survived
so this is a yes no it's letting us know
that this is a 0 or a 1 on here
and then for the class and the
age those are as numeric
there's other ways to process class
since it is a very restricted number on
there but for this we're just going to
do it as a numeric value same thing with
age and you see we didn't do anything
with sex we're just going to leave that
as male or female and that's fine for
this because it'll pick up on that when
we run the decision tree
and we'll do our control enter so now
i've assigned the new df and you can see
it comes down below
as we run it on there so this is now
loaded and df now is a mutated data
frame that we started with and we've set
it up with our specific columns we want
to work with in this case survived class
sex and age and we've formatted three of
those columns to a new setup so one of
them is factor that's where we use for
survive so it knows it's a zero and one
and then we switched class and age to
make sure that it knows that those are
numeric values
now that we have our data formatted we
need to go ahead and split the data into
a training and testing data set
and by now if you've done any of our
other machine learning tutorials you
know this is standard you need to have
your data that we train it with and then
you got to make sure it works on data
that it hasn't trained on
so we'll go ahead and do the splitting
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and when you're dealing with splitting
the data we're doing a little randomness
so we'll just go ahead and set the seed
to one two three you can set that to
whatever number you want that's just
setting the random variable seed
and we'll go ahead and hit enter on
there
and to do this we're going to create
sample and we're gonna go equals
sample dot
split
so we're splitting up the data
this is actually creating a whole new
column
trues and falses it's all stored in
sample and we want our data frame and we
use a dollar sign to denote that we're
going to be working with
one of the different columns a nice
thing you can do in r
and it actually shows my survived so df
survived
and then our split
ratio
split ratio i want to add a period in
there which it doesn't have
our split ratio is going to be equal to
and we'll do 0.70 so we're going to take
70 of the data
of those that have survived and we're
going to just randomly select which one
of those we're going to use for training
and which one we're going to use for
testing it out later
we'll hit our enter and load that sample
in there
and then we'll go ahead and create our
train and our test data set so i'm going
to set train equal to
and this is where kind of gets
interesting because we're going to do
subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our df
where sample
and then we're going to use equals since
this is a logic gate so wherever it sets
sample equal to true
we're going to use that line in df
this is of course
r so it's all capitalized for true
so here's our trained data frame we're
creating so when i execute this and it
shows up down below
it goes up and says hey this sample
created a whole bunch of trues and false
and we're going to take those trues and
falses and wherever we've created a true
which is 70 of the data randomly
selected that's we're going to train the
data with and then we need our test set
and that's a subset just the same thing
we just did
and we need our data frame and this is
where the sample equals
false and again when i hit control enter
it goes down this line of code and it
runs it down here in our terminal window
so now we've nicely split our data up we
have our training data set and our test
data set
and this is of course we get to the
point of what we're actually trying to
do which is create our decision tree
and we're going to do that by training
the decision tree as a classifier
this always gets me you spend all this
work sorting through the data
reformatting it in this case mutating it
and filtering it and creating a train
set and a test set
so we're going to go ahead and create
our tree and we're going to assign to it
the r part
that's the module we imported
and for the our part we need to go ahead
and
do what's called a survived and this is
kind of a little complicated to look at
so let's just take a quick look at this
i'm going to go backward on it the first
part is we're importing the data so data
equals train
and then we want to know is who survived
so
the first part we put in here is the
column we're looking for is survived
and you'll see that we have added the
squiggly mark in the period because
we're looking just for this prediction
we just want to know who survived on
these boats
for programming our decision tree and
i'll go ahead and hit ctrl enter
and we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now in there
and if you remember from before we've
taken from when we did the closet full
of clutter we've done the same thing
where we have our entropy and that one
line computes the entropy and the
increase in information and it brings
entropy down to zero so it's the same
thing but instead of applying it here as
we did visually to the closet it's now
applied it to the data on the ship it's
now looked at the survival of zero or
one based on female male what age they
are where the best split of the age is
and what class they were in
you can see we have first class if we go
down there i think there's
third yeah third second so i guess it's
class one two and three but you can see
that's how we split it up so it's use
these different variables to minimize
the entropy and maximize the information
gain and that's all done in that one
line of code
boy we worked on all that theory and
computer doesn't fear in one line of
code it's important to understand the
theory behind it so you know what's
happening because as they make changes
to these or if you had special settings
on it you have to know what they're
doing
but in this case you can see that we
once we get it formatted the computer
does all the heavy lifting for us
and it never ceases to amaze me just how
advanced machine learning has become
these days and how easy it is for people
to get into it and learn the basic
setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there we want to go
ahead and start doing predictions with
it
and what are we going to predict well
you remember that we created our data
with the train and test so we have our
training data which we programmed the
tree for
now we want to see what it does with the
test data so let's see what that looks
like
and we can wrap that into tree dot
survived dot predicted
we'll assign that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the r
part module that we brought in
i can simply put in here that we're
going to use the tree
we have our test data
and type
this happens to be classification or
class
and this would also be if you were to
distribute this tree you could save the
tree and send it someplace else to be
used on new data this would be the
command line you would use to predict on
here predict you have your tree saved
you have whatever data you're putting
through
and you let it know it's doing a
classification on the tree
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
that's loaded up
and now that we've gone through we've
trained our tree we've run a prediction
on our test data remember the tree had
never seen the test data till now so
we've already built the tree we're just
testing it out
and to do that we're going to use a
confusion matrix for evaluating the
model and let's see what that looks like
that is simply confusion
matrix so once we have the confusion
matrix which came in from our carrot we
need to compare the two different pieces
of data
and the first one is going to be the
value we generated up here we have
tree.survived.predicted
so i'm just going to copy that and paste
it down here and then the second one is
the tree we're comparing that to
let's see survived
it's not the tree it's easy to get
confused sometimes when you're moving
these things around
we're going to compare it to test the
test group of data specifically
the survived column
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and so let's go ahead and scroll up a
little bit here to where it first
executed the confusion matrix
and the most important part of this is
that we have our prediction
and our reference and so zero means they
didn't survive 1 means they survived we
had our prediction on here
versus the actual and that's what these
two columns mean
and so when you read this little chart
we have 0 0 so both the prediction and
the actual reference said agreed on 218
values for people who did not survive a
little grim there for data remember i
talked about this is morbid data talking
about death rates of people on boats it
says that they both agreed on 93 so 93
of them where we predicted the value
that they would survive and the
reference came up the same
likewise
the predicted were predicted one
and the reference said no these people
didn't survive well our prediction got
25 wrong
and where it says they didn't survive
and they actually did and got 57 wrong
and we can come on down with the
confusion matrix and we can look at the
accuracy comes up with the 0.7913
or 95 percent ci
so you're looking at pretty high
accuracy
information ratio p value when you're in
statistics the p-value is one of the
things we look at remember that there
are certain values if it's over 0.95
it's considered highly valuable variable
0.5 means maybe anything less than that
means it's probably not connected
you have to look up the p-value a little
bit more on that then they just have
more information down here
which you can go through
and
which you can go through but the
important part is that we have a very
high accuracy that's what we're looking
at this is a very accurate model and
again always remember the domain you're
working with certainly this is an
example and this is a good little piece
of data you can play with but if i was
say betting money and my accuracy came
up as 79 or over 95 ci i'd be like yes
let's bet on that that's a good bet but
if i was betting on a life or death
situation i might kind of rethink that a
little bit if that is if it's going to
affect my life that way you can also
look at this as if you're trying to
figure out where the boats go in this
particular example and where to put the
lifeboats that's actually pretty good be
able to say hey we can increase the
chances of people surviving this
accident by putting the lifeboats in the
appropriate places
and then this is always fun let's
visualize the decision tree
one of the cool things you can do inside
of r real easily
and if you remember one of the modules
we brought in has a rpart.plot
we're going to take that and we're going
to dump that into the prp for the tree
and let's go ahead and hit enter
and this is fine let me move this over
so you can get a nice view you can see
how it actually split it up and let me
just rerun that again now they expanded
the right you'll see right here where
one of the biggest splits was whether
the person was male or female i didn't
know that was probably one of the
biggest breaks as far as lowering the
entropy and increasing the information
gain
and then once you know sex is male it
came down here and it said you're not
going to survive i guess the men were
throwing themselves overboard on the
boat i don't know maybe they're being
very gallant and letting the women and
children survive which is what i hope
that means
so once you know that it's not a male
and it's a female passenger if you were
in class 3 or above you had a high
chance of surviving if you're less in
class 3 class one or two then it was
based on age and so you can see where
age was greater than 19.
so anybody over 19 had a high chance of
surviving and then if they were or less
than 19 i'm sorry if the age was a
little confusing on that one but if the
age was one side of 19 they probably
survived if not then it said hey if your
age is less than 60 you probably
survived and if not
people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time so
elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that elderly would have a hard
time getting off into the lifeboats and
they would probably step aside for the
younger generation i know i would you
know so that might be more of a social
norm statistic as opposed to survival
rate
let's go and put this back on over here
and see what else we can do with this
data
you know if you're working with the
shareholders it's good to have a lot of
tools as far as how to display you know
they'll want to see this number here
where you say hey this is what the
confusion matrix looks like and we got a
0.79 accuracy that would be like the
number one thing you talk to the
shareholders about other data scientists
care about the p-value and the
information rate and information like
that but this is really the core right
here this is how much data and this also
shows them how much data was looked at
so you have a you can actually just add
these numbers together and you can see
how many different people were in the
this particular data set i mean lines in
the data set but we go ahead and
visualize the 2d decision boundary so
let's take a look at that that's kind of
fun it's a little bit more complicated
so i'm not going to go into it in too
much detail today now the guys in the
back put this code together for me which
is great so i'm just going to paste it
in because like i said we're not going
to go into it into too much detail i
want to just show you that there's some
other ways to display the data that is
not just this nice little tree over here
which gives us a little bit more maybe
view of what's going on as you dig
deeper into data that becomes very
important it might not be something so
simple where you can look at in this
case uh one two three four nodes so they
have four major nodes that they split
the data in
so we're looking at this we're going to
go ahead and create a set test equal to
test comma c241
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data
okay that's what that is
and then we're going to take set and
have it equal to test
and we'll do x1
and we're going to set that equal to
minimum set
of 1 minus 1 max set of 1 plus 1
by equals 0.01
they had to play with these numbers a
little bit to get this to look right so
we're creating a sequence on here from
our the set we created so our test set
and then x2 is also creating a sequence
based on different values
and then we're going to put that all
into a grid so let's go ahead and run
that through all the way down to the
grid
and they'll make a little more sense
when we add the column names to the grid
okay so we'll set our test we'll create
our uh x1 sequence and our x2 sequence
remember a sequence is just like in this
case starting with 0.1 it's like 0.01
0.02 0.03 0.04
so we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01 so that's
all we're doing right now
let's go ahead and set that up there's
our grid
and then we want to go ahead and create
some column names and for our grid set
we're going to have our c class
and age
so we're just doing the class and the
age on here remember we did sex also
before so it's just class and age on
this chart that we're pulling out
and we're going to create a y grid and
the y grid is going to equal tree
survived predicted
okay so here's our y grid and our
predicted values on there
now we're actually going to do something
we're going to plot and we're going to
plot the y grid oops hold on let me see
what's in here
and let me go ahead and just run the
plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and see we can make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
there's a couple things going on
what we've done is we've plotted a
decision tree classification data set
we've done our plot and we have our set
so our sets equal to our test data
and then we have our main we went ahead
and give it a name decision tree
and then we have our x lab
and our x limit and we've set those up
as class
with our y lab equals age and our x
limit equals range x 1 comma y limit
equals range of x2
and when you look over here you can see
that we have age on the left and class
on the bottom
and so based on age and class
and so once we put in this nice graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
contours and our points
so let's go ahead and run that and i'm
going to run all three of these so we
can see
all the colors come in on the graph and
this is actually going to take a little
bit
because remember you can make it go a
little faster by changing a couple of
the notes up here
well we did 0.01 from the min to max
by changing that to 0.1 or other values
you can actually it'll run a little
quicker and we're going to create a nice
little decision tree classification test
set just to see what that looks like and
how that data displays
now that was taking so long to run with
0.01 i went ahead and just did a 0.1 so
instead of filling the whole page with
different colors for a really pretty
view now i just have these different
colored lines coming across it gives us
another model that we can show for
whoever you're working with in this case
your shareholders of the company or the
individuals who you're posting to the
web for and you can see where we have
the green and the red and we've set
those up to identify from the decision
who's going to make it and who's not
based on age and class now my favorite
one on this and i'm going to go back and
just highlight this really quick was let
me just rerun that go back to prp tree
where we display the tree
and that's where we split it in part
because this information
gives us some keys that we can then use
in other models so it's good to know
that sometimes what you're taking comes
out and maybe you create a bucket for
people under 19 between 19 and 60 and
over 60 and different things like that
so you can actually put people in
buckets in a class age split just a
quick note on there again you know lots
of different things from which you can
display the data and you can see how we
use the decision tree to figure out
chances of somebody surviving based on
their class and their age what is a
random forest and welcome to raphael's
vineyard and i don't even know how to
pronounce that in alsace france the
largest wine production region in the
world so they have
centuries of wine production and data
they've collected on how to make the
best how to make their grapes and grow
them and how to properly get the right
grapes and ferment them like raphael
wine makers around the world are facing
a grave problem so let's meet the man
himself and try helping him out what is
a random forest we're going to come back
to the vineyard but we're going to look
at some other examples along the way too
open up the door and of course uh here
comes raphael that probably i'd probably
look closer to raphael than i do to the
young lad with the beard hey raphael so
tell us how it's going not as good as
before not many people work in this
profession anymore so every stage of
production has gone slower if only we
could somehow speed up the process well
lucky for you i'm a machine learning
engineer how about we automate the
quality prediction process for wine let
me begin by telling you what machine
learning in random forest is machine
learning is the science of applying
algorithms that allow a computer to
predict the outcome without being
explicitly programmed random force is an
ensemble machine learning algorithm so
we're bringing in different pieces and
then putting those pieces together it
operates by building multiple decision
trees remember i told you we don't want
just a lone tree out there in the we
want a forest they work for both
classification if you remember from part
one we had our vendor with his broccoli
and oranges i think he also had carrots
and it also the output given by the
majority of its decision trees is the
forest final output so if you have a
number of decision trees you have five
decision trees and four of them say it's
broccoli then it's probably broccoli and
you can also use it as a regression
model the output given by the majority
of decision trees is a forest final
output just like you do in
classification you can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random force works in layman terms it's
always a good thing to explore the
information on something a little bit
easier to understand and see
sure let's consider the case of sam a
high school student this so reminds me
of my own high school student who's just
started his first year in college asking
all his friends so sam is confused on
which course to take up so he's trying
to figure out what his next class is
going to be at school should he take
music lessons dance lessons math science
maybe social studies so he decides to
ask a couple of his friends for
suggestions and sam approaches jane
first so he comes up to jane and says
hey which of these classes should i take
and jane asked sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest
theoretical do you like theory no he
doesn't like the theory part calculative
do you like calculative he goes yes i
like doing calculations and so jane
based on a couple question goes she has
a little decision tree there going she
goes mathematics sounds good so james
forms a decision tree based on sam's
response and gives her suggestion and of
course this is based on jane's views and
her history and the data that she's
collected over her years in high school
next sam approach is bella bella asks
him hey do you like the field of science
and sam goes yes and then bella goes do
you like
new in industry he like new things
coming up in industry and sam goes yes
and bella goes you know you should
similar to jane bella also forms a
decision tree based on sam's response
and gives her suggestion and says hey
how about artificial intelligence sam's
like oh artificial intelligence so sam
next asks terry for his suggestion
and sam goes do you like scoring things
and he goes yes
and he goes do you like theoretical and
he goes no and he comes up and says
mathematics so you have two people
saying mathematics and one's a person
suggesting artificial intelligence
since two out of three friends suggested
math sam decides to take mathematics and
there's a lot of subtleties in this
example it's actually a really good
example some of the things we run into
in data science is when we collect data
and we collect from different sources we
might have data from one source that
measures one thing or one set of
instruments and we might have data from
another source that measures something
else we saw that with each of his
friends are measuring different things
and asking different questions that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
particular tutorial so let's go back to
our wine cellar so you see more the
number of decision trees more accurate
will be the prediction random forests
have a number of applications in market
already if you've been watching any of
our other tutorials you'll see that
these are very common we have in banking
it can be used to predict fraudulent
customers it is used to analyze symptoms
of patients in detecting the disease
in e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends can be analyzed to
predict profit or loss
most recently i was watching a review on
weather here in the united states and
the data they pull in for that and one
of the top weather places actually uses
five different models random forest was
one of them i believe these five
different models to predict the weather
and depending on what the models come up
with and what's going on some of the
models do better than others i thought
that was really interesting it's
important to note so when you see us
repeat the same things over and over and
you're looking at the different machine
learning tools you realize that we use
multiple tools to solve the same problem
and we can find the best one that fits
for that particular situation so let's
see how that fits back in our wine
production to help speed up the process
of wine production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality suppose our
random forest builds three decision
trees we have the first decision tree
which is going to divide everything by
chlorides less than 0.08 and it's either
yes or no and then it's going to look at
alcohol greater than six yes or no
quality equals high quality not so good
and if the chlorides were greater than
0.08 quality equals low so there's our
first tree and then our second tree is
going to split it on sulfates less than
0.6 and ph ph less than 3.5 and again we
have it coming down here that if the ph
is low and the sulfites are low the
quality equals high if the ph is a
little higher but the sulfides are low
it's not so good and if the sulfides are
greater than 0.6 we have a quality
equals low and then we'll do a third
decision tree we'll split it based on ph
and we can see below how that tree looks
like with our sugar less than 2.5 if not
it's a quad equals low it's real low
quality and if it is less than 2.5 then
the ph decide whether it's going to be a
quality five or not so good and if we
track one of our winds down the list
we'll look at it we'll say oh two out of
three decision trees indicate the
quality of our wine to be fine the
forest predicts the same so this sounds
promising so let's go ahead and dive in
and see what that actually looks like so
this is the data set that holds all the
attribute values required to predict the
wine's quality and i'll pull this up in
a spreadsheet in just a moment but you
can see here we have fixed acidity
volatile acidity citric acid all the way
to quality and then quality is like a
four five six or seven i believe and
this will be done in r so let's go ahead
and get started in our coding we'll be
using rstudio before we dive into our
studio i always like to open up the data
in the spreadsheet and look at the
actual data that i have
and they've called it wine quality dash
red.xls
so it's a spreadsheet a microsoft
spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before as far as the
slide was showing us with the we have 12
different columns the first 11 are our
features our fixed acidity volatile acid
citric acid things you always want to
look at when you're looking at your data
and we've done this before in the part
one but just a reminder we want to note
that we have decimal places here float
values
and a lot of these things especially the
first number of columns
our free sulfur dioxide looks to be
an integer but it varies a lot so we
have you know i see some values all the
way up to 51
7 4.
so we'd probably keep this as a linear
model kind of thing same thing with the
sulfur dioxides densities again decimal
places sulfides alcohol
quality i want you to note in the
quality
that we only have a few qualities here
this isn't
like a spread between zero and a hundred
it looks to be three four five six and
seven
and so when we start looking at the
processes we can have the option of
either doing this
as a
series of integers or float values going
from
3 to 7 or we can convert that to a
categorical 3 4 5 6 and 7 being the
categories but we'll look at that in the
coding here in just a minute and finally
you'd want to go ahead and scroll down
through the data and just look for
missing data or anything weird
obviously working with big data you
wouldn't be able to do that if this was
spread across numerous computers and you
had millions of
rows we have what sixteen hundred and
eighty seven rows here so it's a nice
size spreadsheet still considered a
small data set
let's go ahead and switch over and let's
take a look at this in the r
so here we are in our r studio
and if you remember it's uh comes up
automatically in three panels i have my
font on fairly large to help out
the upper left panel is a file that's
open you can have multiple files and
tabs open as you can see on mine right
now i'll probably close most of those in
just a minute
and this is where you can put in your
commands
then you can execute these commands by
either clicking on the run box or
control enter is the hotkeys for that
and all that does is then puts it down
in the console and executes that line of
command you could just paste these
directly in the console i've certainly
been known to do that if i'm loading up
some data and i just want to take a
quick look at it in r because i'm doing
the coding in something else or if i
just want to do a quick explore before i
dive in and figure out what needs to be
done that's one of the tricks you can do
and then on the right hand side we have
our environment history connections
we mainly are going to just be sitting
on plots and i'm just going to minimize
this for right now out of the way when
we dive in if you haven't yet you do
need to go ahead and install the package
random forest i'm not actually going to
do that because i've already run that we
don't need to rerun that but i am going
to go ahead and import it into our
project with the library and then random
forest and we'll do the control enter
you can always hit the run button up
there too
and then now the library has been
uploaded in there and you can see down
below it takes us and just copies it and
pastes it down below and runs it in our
console
and then just a quick troubleshooting
thing my java happens to be the
developer's job the latest release of
the developers java from last week is
clashing with my r and rerouting my uh
java files so your chances are you don't
need to to look this up or find out
where your java is but there's a jre
folder if you do have an error that
comes up next in the next library you
look that up it's usually under program
files java and you'll see jdk depending
on what version you have on there and
then find that jre folder and i'm just
going to set the environment on there
you have to do that every time you run
the script so with r there is a place in
r where you can set it permanently but
generally it's set to whatever your
system variables are set to so you don't
want to mess with that so you just want
to put this in your code if you're
having problems you can always take it
out then we need to go ahead and bring
in another library
and we're going to be importing a
the spreadsheet so it's an x the
xlsx since it's a microsoft spreadsheet
and i'll go ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're going to assign to variable
path the location of our folder so this
is a very lengthy one you'll have to
copy and paste it off your computer my
name is richard and you can see here
it's under seek column users richer's
documents docs business simply learn
marketing
random forest and then the actual file
which is wine quality dash red.xls
so i put in the whole path in here you
could also set the computer path to
whatever folder you have it in and then
just use just the name of the file but i
went ahead and did this because it a lot
of times it's good to be aware where
your paths are going where you're
pulling your data from and again i went
the control enter so i could you'll see
that that pushed the line down below and
ran that line so our path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
data
and we'll assign that to a read
and we're going to be reading let's see
where is it there it is and spreadsheet
and before i put in
we need the path
but we also need one more thing on the
spreadsheet because it is an excel
spreadsheet we need to know
which
page we're on so let's go look that up
and in the spreadsheet this might be a
little hard to see because it's a very
tiny font down there but you'll see the
page tabs on the bottom this actually
has two different pages and we want page
one for this project so let's flip back
over and put that in our code and the
term they use is sheet
index i always have to look that stuff
up
and it was sheet index of one we'll go
ahead and execute this
so at this point we've now loaded the
data into the variable data
and it's reading those and i think there
was like a couple thousand rows of data
in there so it takes it just a moment to
pull it in
once i have my data in there i always
like to do something like this
data
and in
always forgetting r it's head data
and we can run that
and you'll see it prints out that what
we looked at in the spreadsheet so we
have our fixed
acidity
volatile acidity citric acid residual
sugar chlorides free sulfur all the
different things
we're actually looking for quality so
you want to keep that in mind that
quality is the final setting is it a
three four five six what is the quality
on there
and the first thing we need to do is
we're actually going to take the data
quality
and let me see quality there it is
in r the dollar sign means that you're
looking at one of the columns in here or
features as it is so we see data dollar
sign quality and r that means that's
what we're going to be editing
and what we want to do is we want to
change the quality just a little bit
and so we're going to set it equal to
now we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so data
dollar sign quality equals and we want
to do as is one of the functions in r
we're going to do as a factor
and then data
quality because that's what we're
actually editing on there and this stop
just for a second to look at this
factor takes this
and looks at the data
as a
categorically so instead of it being on
a continual scale of you know
0 to 100 or something like that it
actually looks at it as category of five
category of six category of a category
of cat category of dog
there are yes or no categories versus a
continual now there's a lot of different
things in here that we can do the same
thing with
but all of these really are
linear numbers 7.4 0.70
sulfur dioxide 34 67 so we really don't
need to mess with any of the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here and do our control enter and it'll
run it down below
and you'll see data quality equals as
factor data quality so we've now turned
that into a factor or into a categorical
data
and so let me just bring this down a
little bit the guys in the back did the
rest of this next piece of code
there are so many different ways and if
you have been
looking at any of our tutorials
this should look kind of familiar this
is one way to do it
you'll see we have our training data and
our testing data and so we've done here
is we've got it we have a data set size
equals
and we're just going to do by the row
and so we want point eight or eighty
percent of the data is going to be our
training set to train our forest and if
you train it forest or any
machine learning model of course want to
test it so we're going to save 20
percent of the data for testing
and when you look at this we have the
index
which we set at 80 percent comma and
then a negative index so that's the
remaining setup so it goes from that
index on this is our notation for
sorting out that data
and then we create the index
and we use the term sample
and this is just going to go in there
and set our different samples for n row
size data set size and everything so we
have an index now so the data is indexed
and we're just going to pull off the
first set of index and the end of the
index for our data and we can run all of
this in one shot
we'll go under code
and we'll run
selected lines and so now we have our
data in here we have our training set
and our testing set that's what we
wanted to get to
so once we've formatted all the data
then we get to the next real easy step
which is a single line to bring in our
random forest
so let's go ahead and we'll use the
variable rf standing for random forest
and we're going to assign
if you remember correctly we brought in
our library random
if you wonder why i go up here all the
time it's because i'll forget which
letters are capitalized in some of these
because they switch between packages so
much but it's random with a capital f
for 4s random forest so the rf is going
to equal random forest
and of course the
we start by telling it which column
we're trying to predict
and of course we can always go down here
and double check we're running this on
the
quality there we go quality and we're
using just that column all the way to
the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over what they did but i'm going to put
in the values that they have set for the
different options in the random forest
before i do that it would help if i tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal
our training set
and then we have the variables that they
put together and let's just talk a
little bit about what these different
variables mean
so ha m try and entry these are some of
the variables you play with with the
random forest the m try not so much
when they first put it out i think m try
was very common four is a good value i
can't remember what the default is but
it's probably three four or five or
something like that depending i think it
depends on how many features you have
going in there so you could even just
leave this as a default without too much
troubles
the entry this is where it gets
important and i'm going to make this
one of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tie breaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501
and then finally we have importance
equals true i can't remember what it
defaults to but generally you want to
set the importance equals to true it
actually looks at the correlation
between the different features to make
sure that there is some kind of
correlation as it's doing its
calculations so our one line of code is
going to assign our random forest and go
ahead and train our random force all in
one execution so this whole thing has
been centered around getting to rf set
to the random forest
and let's go ahead and execute this
variable or this line of code and you'll
see it takes a little bit down here to
execute as it goes through and sets it
up
and you'll see it probably takes a
minute or so to execute the code
depending on the size of the data and
how good your machine is
and then with all of our data we can
start looking at the answers we'll just
do rf we'll execute that
and you'll see that the random forest
does a nice job you can see right here
it has our date equals training it
basically goes over everything we talked
about
and you come down here and it has a
confusion matrix which is nice we always
like our confusion matrix when we're
talking to our shareholders and
explaining what the data comes out with
and how it trains
and we can go ahead and plot our rf
let's see what that looks like
and
as the number of force grows remember we
set it to 2001 forest you can also see
how the error comes in how the different
error on the different variables
this kind of a nice graph that gives you
an idea it might help you adjust whether
you really want to do 2000 different
forests you might actually truncate this
off at around maybe 800 because you
notice the lines kind of continue on
again this is just still on the plot
and of course the next step is we need
to go ahead and predict remember we
split our data into two groups
so let's go ahead and get a result we'll
call it result and we'll assign this one
there we go
we'll set this to a data frame
there we go there's our data frame
and then oh let's call this we have our
test our test
quality because that's what we're we're
setting up on our test group with the
quality on there
then we wanted to have a predict
nice little keyword there to go and run
our random for us
and then we tell it that we're going to
predict using our rf our random forest
our testing group
1 to 11 is what we're using type equals
response
so let's go ahead and execute it that's
a mouthful on there
somewhere i left out a comma in there so
it gave me an error but you can see
right here we've set in there now we
have a result and just real quick we
could do the head of the result
result comma 5 and just take a look at
the first five lines and you'll see we
have the actual value and what we
predicted over here
and we could also just do all of the
results and just see what that looks
like oops
and print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
there we go we'll put plot up here plot
and let's plot the result
and just see what that looks like
maybe not the best one to show to the
shareholders but does give you an idea
on the left on the y-axis you'll see
that it predicted eight
and this tells you that a lot of the
eight and the eight scale was pretty
probably gave us
about fifty percent came up there at
eight
really maybe 50 it didn't guess right
but it did come up there and say that it
was at least a four or five or six even
where it was considered an eight and so
on you can see these different blocks
coming in so that if you line up the
three with the three
four with the four and you kind of cross
index them a heat map would probably do
better but for this example we'll just
do a quick plot of the data
as far as how it works and you can again
see the results that we predicted over
here and you can look those over
of course back in the wine cellar we're
talking to our vineyard owner and if you
remember from before we looked at this
chart right here the error rate is 29.05
percent
therefore our accuracy is
70.95 percent
if you're doing a vineyard that's
probably pretty good accuracy and always
check your domain when you're sharing
this stuff because if you're doing
something that's life or death
maybe 70 accuracy might not be so good
but if you're looking at where you're
going to distribute the bottles to for
the wine and who's going to drink it you
know 70 percent accuracy is pretty good
for that that's probably a lot better
than having no accuracy whatsoever and
not even knowing what wine is going out
to who so we have automated the process
of predicting the quality of wine i
myself prefer to predict it by sampling
it that's great thank you i'd like to
visit this guy and sample his wine and
find out just how good his different
vineyards are what is clustering so
we'll have a group of people here
hanging out at a table or local coffee
shop i'm guessing coffee shops since
they all have the same mugs and one of
them is trying to figure out what
they're going to do i have 20 places to
cover in four days i guess he's going
traveling that sounds fun one of those
breeze through costa rica or visiting
the us or going to to europe to go visit
all the highlights so he's got 20 places
he wants to go and he wants to hit him
in four days very ambitious
and how will i manage to cover all of
them that's the question that he's
coming up how am i going to get to all
these different places in the short time
i have maybe he's a sales team so he has
20 places he's got to do demos for you
can make use of clustering by grouping
the places into four clusters
each of these clusters will have places
which are close by so we're going to
cluster them together by what is closest
to the other one then each day you can
visit one cluster and cover all the
places in the cluster great that's a
great idea you know if you're going to
hit uh four different places maybe
you're going to cluster whatever streets
are closest together so you don't have
to travel spend all your time traveling
the method of dividing the objects into
clusters which are similar between them
and are dissimilar to the objects
belonging to another cluster so this is
a formal definition of clustering and we
have here what we call hierarchical
clustering and partial clustering and
we're going to go more into detail on
hierarchical clustering and you'll see
the difference between the two where
partial clustering doesn't have the
descending graph it just has groups of
things
and under hierarchical clustering we're
going to go over agglomerative and
divisive and you can think of
agglomerative of bringing things
together and divisive as dividing them
apart and then partial clustering the
two most common ones are k-means that's
probably the most common use for partial
clustering and there's also fuzzy c
means and there's other ways of
clustering and other algorithms out
there but these are the two big ones
k-means really being the most common one
used but we're not going to dig too deep
into partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering are pretty
numerous we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of belong
together how do we group them together
we have a social network analysis so
social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest new sales for them
you know this whole group is into
harley-davidson motorcycles so we cater
to them to sell them harley-davidson
motorcycle parts and we find out that
people in that group also like leather
jackets they also like uh motorcycle
boots and they like bandanas my
brother's in harley-davidson so
that's why i picked that kind of funny
example but you can kind of see we look
for similarities between these people
and then we group them together
accordingly and that's a good
sentimental clustering is very common in
so many things today we want to know the
sentiments on stocks who is interested
in stocks who's not sentimental analysis
we talked about customer segmentation in
cells well we want to know what kind of
sentimental view people have on
different restaurants if we're going to
open up a new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course city
planning a lot of this i just kind of
aimed at the city planning side sitting
planning is big with clustering we want
to cluster things together so that they
work we don't want to put a industrial
zone in the middle of somebody's
neighborhood where they're not going to
enjoy it or have a commercial zone right
in the middle of the industrial zone
where no one's going to want to go next
to a factory to go eat a high-end meal
or dinner so it's very big in city
planning it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models so
when we're exploring data being able to
cluster things together reveal things in
the data we never thought about and then
once we have it clustered we can put
that into another model to help us
figure out what it is we want for our
solution so let's go a little deeper
into hierarchical clustering let's
consider we have a set of cars and we
have a group similar we want to group
similar ones together so below we have
you'll see four different cars down
there and we get two clusters of car
types sedan and suv so if you're just
looking at it you can probably think oh
yeah we'll put the sedans together and
the suvs together and then at last we
can group everything into one cluster so
we just have just cars so you can see as
we have this we make a nice little tree
this is very common when you see anybody
talks about hierarchical clustering this
is usually what you see and what comes
out of it we terminate when we are left
with only one cluster so we have as you
can see we bring them all together we
have one cluster we can't bring it
together anymore because they're all
together hierarchical clustering is
separating data into different groups
based on some measure of similarity so
we have to find a way to measure what
makes them alike and what makes them
different agglomerative clustering is
known as a bottom up approach remember i
said think of that as bringing things
together you see
i think the latin term aglow is together
because you have your conglomerate rocks
where all the different pieces of rocks
are in there so we want to bring
everything together that's a bottom up
and then divisive is we're going to go
from the top down so we take one huge
cluster and we start dividing it up into
two clusters into three four five and so
on digging even deeper into how
hierarchical clustering works
let's consider we have a few points on a
plane so this plane is 2d so we have an
xy coordinates kind of makes it easy
we're going to start with measure the
distance so we want to figure a way to
compute the distance between each point
each data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up agglomerative then we have each point
being its own cluster we try to find the
least distance between two data points
to form a cluster and then once we find
those with the least distance between
them we start grouping them together so
we start forming clusters of multiple
points this is represented in a
tree-like structure called dendogram so
this is another key word dendogram and
you can see it is it's just a branch
we've looked at before and we do the
second group the same so it gets its own
dendogram and the third gets its own
dendogram and then we might group two
groups together so now those two groups
are all under one dendogram because
they're closer together than the p1 and
p2 and then we terminate when we are
left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together you can see on the
right how we've come up all the way up
to the top whoops and we have the gray
hierarchical box coming in there and
connecting them so we have just one
cluster and that's a good place to
terminate because there is no way we can
bring them together any further so how
do we measure the distance between the
data points
i mean this is really where it starts
getting interesting up until now you can
kind of eyeball and say hey these look
together but when you have thousands of
data points how are we going to measure
those distances and there is a lot of
ways to get the distance measure so
let's go and take a look at that
distance measures will determine the
similarity between two elements and it
will influence the shape of the clusters
and we have euclidean distance measure
we have squared euclidean distance
measure which is almost the same thing
but with less computations and we have
the manhattan distance measure which
will give you slightly different results
and we have the cosine distance measure
which again is very similar to the
euclidean playing with triangles and
sometimes it can compute faster
depending on what kind of data you're
looking at so let's start with the
clitorian distance measure the most
common is we want to know the distance
between the two points so if we have
point p and point q the euclidean
distance is the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space and you should
recognize d equals in this case we're
going to sum all the points so if there
was more than one point we could figure
out the distance to the not more than
one points this is the sum of more than
two dimensions
so we can have the distance between each
of the different dimensions squared and
that will give us and then take the
square root of that and that gives us
the actual distance between them and
they should look familiar from euclidean
geometry maybe you haven't played too
much with multiple dimensions so the
summation symbol might not look familiar
to you but it's pretty straightforward
as you add the distance between each of
the two different points squared so if
your y difference was 2 minus 1 squared
would be 2 and then you take the
difference between the x again squared
and if there was a z coordinates it
would be you know z1 minus z2 squared
and then take the square root of that
and sum it all or sum it all together
and then take the square root of it so
to make it compute faster since the
difference in distances whether one is
farther apart or closer together than
the other we can do what's called the
squared euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the euclidean
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end there's no reason to it
certainly gives us the exact distance
but as far as doing calculations as to
which one's bigger or smaller than the
other one it won't make a difference so
we'll just go with the so we just get
rid of that that final square root
computes faster and it gives us the
pretty much euclidean squared distance
on there now the manhattan distance
measurement is a simple sum of
horizontal and vertical components or
the distance between two points measured
along axes at right angles now this is
different because you're not looking at
the direct line between them and in
certain cases the individual distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with the euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the manhattan distance is you
measure just the y value and you take
the absolute value of it and you measure
just the x difference you take the
absolute value of it and just the z and
if you had more you know different
dimensions in there a b c d e f however
many dimensions you would just take the
absolute value of the difference of
those dimensions
and then we have the cosine distance
similarity measures the angle between
the two vectors and as you can see as
the two vectors get further and further
apart the cosine distance gets larger so
it's another way to measure the distance
very similar to the euclidean so you're
still looking at the same kind of
measurement so should have a similar
result as the first two but keep in mind
the manhattan will have a very different
result and you can end up with a bias
with the manhattan if your data is very
skewed if one set of values is very
large and another set of values is very
small but that's a little bit beyond the
scope of this it's just important to
know that about the manhattan distance
so let's dig into the agglomerative
clustering and agglometric clustering
begins with each element as a separate
cluster and then we merge them into a
larger cluster how do we represent a
cluster of more than one point so we're
going to kind of mix the distance
together with the actual agglomerative
and see what that looks like and we're
actually going to have three key
questions that are going to be answered
here so how do we represent a cluster
more than one point so we want to look
at the math what it looks like
mathematically and geometrically how do
we determine the nearness of clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your computer script
or your whatever you're working on have
a termination point so it's not in going
on internally
we've all done that if you do any kind
of computer programming or writing a
script let's assume that we have six
data points in a euclidean space so
again we're dealing with x y and z in
this case just x and y
so how do we represent a cluster more
than one point let's take a look at that
and first we're going to make use of
centroids very common terminology in a
lot of machine learning languages when
we're grouping things together so we're
going to make use of centroids which is
the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2 1 and we're going to
group them together because they're
close and if we were looking at all the
points we look for those that are
closest and start with those and we're
going to take those two we're going to
compute a point in the middle and we'll
give that point 1
point five one point five and that's
going to be the centroid of those two
points and next we start measuring like
another group of points we got four one
five zero when they're pretty close
together so we'll go ahead and set up a
centroid of those two points in this
case it would be the 4.5 and
0.5 would be the measurements on those
two points and once we have the centroid
of the two groups we find out that the
next closest point to a centroid is over
on the left and so we're going to take
this and say oh 0 0 is closest to the
1.5 1.5 centroid so let's go ahead and
group that together and we compute a new
centroid based on those three points so
now we have a centroid of 1.1 or 1 comma
1. and then we also do this again with
the last point the 5 3 and it computes
into the first group and you can see our
dendrogram on the right is growing so we
have each of these points are become
connected and we start grouping them
together and finally we get a centroid
of that group two and then finally the
last thing we want to do is combine the
two groups by their centroids and you
can see here we end up with one large
group and it'll have its own centroid
although usually they don't compute the
last centroid we just put them all
together
so when do we stop combining clusters
well hopefully it's pretty obvious to
you in this case when they all got to be
one but there are actually many
approaches to it
so first pick a number of clusters k up
front and this is done in the fact that
we don't want to look at 200 in clusters
we only want to look at the top five
clusters or something like that so we
decide the number of clusters required
in the beginning and we terminate when
we reach the value k
so if you looked back on our clustering
let me just go back a couple screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might want just the two
clusters and so we look at just the top
two or maybe we only want three clusters
and so we would compute which one of
these has a wider spread to it or
something like that there's other
computations to know how to connect them
and we'll look at that in just a minute
but to note that when we pick the k
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in so that can be very
important especially if you're feeding
it into another algorithm that requires
three values or you set it to four
values and you need to know that value
coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay only three
clusters that's all we want for k so the
possible challenges this only makes
sense when we know the data well so when
you're clustering with k clusters you
might already know that domain and know
that that makes sense but if you're
exploring brand new data you might have
no idea how many clusters you really
need to explore that data with let's
consider the value of k to be 2. so in
this case in our previous example we
stop and we are left with two clusters
and you can see here that this is where
they came together the best while still
keeping separate the data the second
approach is stop when the next merge
would create a cluster with low cohesion
so we keep clustering until the next
merge of clusters creates a bad cluster
low cohesion set up on there that means
the point is so close to being between
two clusters it doesn't make sense to
bring them together but how is cohesion
defined oh let's dig a little deeper
into cohesion the diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual diameter
of our cluster and the diameter is the
maximum distance between any pair of
points in the cluster we terminate when
the diameter of a new cluster exceeds
the threshold so as that diameter gets
bigger and bigger we don't want the two
circles or clusters to overlap
and we have radius of a cluster radius
is the maximum distance of a point from
centroid we terminate when the radius of
a new cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and is overlapping with other
data we stop so let's look at divisive
clustering remember we went from the
bottom up now we want to go from the top
down divisive clustering approach begins
with a whole set and proceeds to divide
it into smaller clusters
so we start with a single cluster
composed of all the data points we split
it into different clusters this can be
done using monotheistic divisive methods
what is a monothetic divisive method and
we'll go backwards and let's consider
the example we took in the agglomerative
clustering to understand this
so we consider a space with six points
in it just like we did before same
points we had before and we name each
point in the cluster so we have in this
case we just gave it a letter value a b
c d e f
since we follow top down approach and
divisive clustering obtain all possible
splits into two columns so we want to
know where you could split it here and
we could do like a a b split and a cdef
split we could do bce adf and you can
see this starts generating a huge amount
of data a b c d e f
and so for each split we can compute
cluster sum of squares
and we can see here the actually have
the formula out for us b j 12 equals n1
of absolute value of x minus absolute
value of x squared so again we're
computing all the different distances in
their squared back to your kind of
euclidean distances on that and so we
can actually compute b and j between
clusters one and two and we have the
mean of the cluster and the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest sum of squares
let's assume that the sum of squared
distance is largest for the third split
we had up above and that's where we
split the abc out and if we split the
abc out we're left with the def on the
other side
we again find the sum of square
distances and split it into clusters so
we go from abc we might find that the a
splits into bc and d into e f
and again you start to see that
hierarchical dendrogram coming down as
we start splitting everything apart and
finally we might have a splits in b and
c and then each one gets their own def
and it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or until we get to k
if we have set a k value so we've kind
of learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math in
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive into a demo and our demo today
is going to be
for the problem statement we're going to
look at u.s oil so a u.s oil
organization needs to know it cells in
various states in u.s and cluster the
states based on the cells so what are
the steps involved in setting this
problem up so the steps we're going to
look at and this is really useful for
just about any processing of data
although i believe we're going to be
doing this in r today we're going to
import the data set so we'll explore our
data a little bit there create a scatter
plot it's always good to have a visual
if you can once you have a visual you
can know if you're really far off in the
model you choose to cluster the data in
or how many splits you need and then
we're going to normalize the data so
we're going to fix the data so it
processes correctly we'll talk more
detail about normalization when we get
there and then calculate the euclidean
distance
and finally we'll create our dendogram
so it looks nice and pretty and we have
something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money and salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up our and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really it has some nice features in it
it automatically sets up the three
windows where we have our script file on
the upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console bottom left and execute it and
then we have our plots off to the right
and i've got it zoomed in hopefully not
too large a font but large enough that
you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data
and we're going to assign it in r this
is a symbol for assigning and we're
going to go read csv
read csv file
and put that in brackets
and let's before we go any further let's
just look at the data outside of r it's
always nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv
this would also be the time to get the
full path so you have the right path to
your file
and remember that you can always post in
the comments down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on and you can repeat it and see
how this works this is utilities.csv
it's a comma separated variable file so
it's pretty straightforward and you can
see here they have the city fixed charge
and a number of different features to
the data and so we have our ror cost
load demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have u.s cities
arizona boston they have central u.s so
i guess they're grouping a number of
areas together
the commonwealth area you can see down
here in nevada new england northern us
oklahoma the pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so i'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way
upside an extra set of brackets here
somehow maybe i missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or in this case i got double
brackets on each side
there we go
and then the magic hot keys in this case
are your control enter
which will let me go ahead and run the
script
and so i've now loaded the data and as
you can see i went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the window down below
and we can simply convert the data to a
string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just print it all
out as a string and then we get this
huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so
when you can see here they have you can
probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head
and we'll do the head of my data
there we go and ctrl enter on that and
the head shows the first five rows
you'll see this in a lot of different
scripts in r it's you type in head and
then in brackets you put your data and
it comes through in this the first five
rows as you can see below
and it shows arizona boston central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the ror
the cost the load the
d demand i'm not an expert in oil so i'm
not even sure what d demand is
cells i'm guessing nuclear how much of
it supplied by nuclear
and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in are different areas
and one of the wonders of r is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs
and pairs creates a nice graph let me go
ahead and run this
whoops the reason it gave me an error is
because i forgot to resize it so let me
bring my plot way out so we can see it
and let's run that again
and
you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
i would look at this and say hey this is
a great
candidate for
some kind of clustering and the reason
is is when i look at any two pairs let's
go down to say sales and fuel costs
towards the bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together but it's a little
confusing you can't really pinpoint how
they group together you could probably
look at these two and say yeah there's
pretty good commonalities there and if
you look at any of the other pairs
you'll start seeing some patterns there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together not just any two of them but
the whole setup
let me go ahead and shrink my um this
down for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a
scatter plot
and this is simply just use the term
plot in brackets
and then which values do we want to plot
and if we remember when we looked at the
data earlier let me just go back this
way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
we'll do fuel cost and cells
and it's in my data
so we let it know which two columns
we're looking at next to each other
and it will open up our plot thing and
then go ahead and execute that
and we can see on those close up of what
we were just looking at in the pairs
and if i was eyeballing this i would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and
this one it's hard to tell which cluster
to be with but maybe it's six you go in
the top one and you have a middle
cluster and a bottom cluster maybe two
different clusters so you can sort of
group them together fuel cost and the
cells and see how they connect with each
other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people on the back
they sent me the script so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text fuel cost cells the labels equal
city
position four
these are numbers you can kind of play
with till they look nice
and oops again i forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
i must type something in here
oh i did a lowercase d and they did a
capital d there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see a little
hard to see on my screen with all the
different things in there it plots the
actual cities so we can now see where
all the cities are in connection with in
this case fuel cost and cells
so we have a nice label to go with the
graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do
oh the r o r oops
and we'll do that
also with the
cells
and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's gonna i'm
surprised it didn't give me an error
and then we'll also add in the
with statement so we put some nice
labels in there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the field cost
cells we want the r cells and we'll
execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because i shrunk it down so let's redo
those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the ror with cells and we'd probably get
a slightly different clustering here if
i was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together and
those kind of go together but again
we're going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step we're going to start
looking at a little bit of coding or
scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization
and if you've done any of the other
machine learning
skills and setup this should start to
look very normal in your pre-processing
of data whether you're in r or python
or any of these scripts we really want
to make sure you normalize your data so
it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if i have let's say the rors even
look at this graph here on the right
you can see where my ror varies between
8 and fourteen
that's a very small variable and our
cells varies between four thousand and
sixteen thousand
so you can imagine the distance between
four thousand and eight thousand which
is a distance of four thousand versus 8
to 10 versus 2
the cells is going to dominate so if we
do any kind of special work on this
it's going to look at cells and it's
going to cluster them just by the cells
alone and then ror might have a little
tiny effect of 2 versus 4 000
we want to level the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize
so i'm just going to put in
the code that they put together in the
back for me and let's talk about it a
little bit so we have z we're going to
assign it to my data
and it's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows
or i mean across all columns so each of
the rows are going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get m which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to
my data so again we want to go ahead and
create a the most
common variable in there
and then s is going to be sd stands for
standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with normalization of data
is we just reshape the data everything
between zero and one
so that if the lower end is eight that
now becomes zero and the upper end is
fourteen that now becomes one
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data
so with this we're going to look for the
means and the standard deviation for
reshaping the data
and that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation
to be equal amongst all of them and then
finally we go ahead and take z and with
the z we're going to reassign it and
we're going to scale the original my
data which we re shaped based on m and
based on the standard deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at everything in kind of a x y
kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter control enter
control enter so now we have z which is
a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu
there we go
and in
r this is so easy once you've gotten to
here we've done all that pre data
processing
we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist
so dist
is
the computation for getting the
euclidean distance
and we can just put z in there because
we've already reformatted and scaled z
to fit what we want let me go ahead and
just hit enter on that
and i'm going to widen my left hand side
again
i'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in distance
which will print the variable down below
oops
you have to hit ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and i don't know about you but when i
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than i see
two three four five six
and then you kind of have the top part 6
17 18.
so imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
equal three and let's run that
also keep forgetting that it
has to go through the graph on the right
and we see a different slightly
different output in here let me just
open this up so we can see we're looking
at
and by cutting down the distance you can
start to see the patterns here if it's
looking at the different distances
so if i go to the top we have the
distance between one and two
one and three one and four one and five
one and six and then two and three
and so on obviously distance between
itself is zero and it doesn't repeat the
data so we don't care to see two versus
one again because we already know the
distance between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits
oh let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh if something's way off
but we have a nice setup and we can see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
h cluster
and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances
so the age clustering does all the work
for us
and then we hit enter on there so now we
have our hcl which is assigned the h
clustering computation based on
distances and apart and then i'm going
to expand my graph because we would like
to go ahead and see what this looks like
and we can simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs
and look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendogram
except when i look at it the first thing
i notice is it really shows like numbers
down below
now if you were a shareholder and some
data scientist came up to you and said
look at this this is what it means you'd
be looking at that going what the heck
does 3 9 14 19 1 18 mean
so let's give it some words there
so let's do the same plot with our hcl
hc there we go
and let's add in labels and this is just
one of the commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that
oops i accidentally ran just hang my one
let me try that again
there we go okay so now you can see what
it's done and the hang my one turns it
sideways that way we can see uh central
which is central us and kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup
and the information you start looking at
is that
when we put all the information together
you probably want to look at central
america and kentucky together
oklahoma and texas has a lot of
commonality as does arizona and southern
u.s
and you can even group all five of those
florida oklahoma texas arizona and
southern u.s
these regions for some reason share a
lot of similarities and so we want to
start asking what those similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do is there's also we can do the
dendogram average
and